- It's like we called each
other with our color palette.
- I know.
And with Ashton too.
- Oh my God. Right?
I know.
- Yes.
- Happy Valentine's Day.
- Happy Valentines day
- Happy Valentine's Day. Yeah
- [ Kelly ] I wanna
know, how did y'all meet?
Was it in Nashville?
- It was
- [ Kelly ] Okay.
- But it was on the old Bumble app.
- Bumble
- Bumble!
- And I know, right?
This is not, it's not an
ad, it's not an endorsement.
- Yeah.
- Middle of the pandemic.
What better time to be on a dating app?
You know?
Is it everyone's on their couch.
- [ Kelly ] Yeah.
- So Well,
- yeah, we, we were,
- we swiped
- I was, we swiped right.
Well, I swiped first cuz the girl
has to swipe first.
- Oh, is that true?
- Yes. So you have to
initiate like, you know, so
you're not bombarded.
(Laughter)
- That didn't happen.
That didn't happen much.
But when I, when I swiped
and I was like, oh my gosh
he's so handsome.
Is he real?
And then I guess the funny part is
that he thought he was
being catfished because I
didn't put much on my bio .
- I think everyone gets scared of that.
Everyone gets scared of that .
- Yeah. Regardless if you're on a TV show,
people can be (beep)
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And we know there's a
show called Catfish Show.
So we know it's real.
- [ Kelly ] I know,
- Right. Which is scary.
So. Yeah.
But I didn't put much
in my bio for that reason cuz I was like
oh well somebody will actually
engage in conversation
if they're interested and
not for the wrong reasons.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah. No. So
- yeah
- I basically had to beg him to
ask for my phone number.
- Oh cuz do you not do that on Bumble?
You have to go through
the app or something.
- You keep talking through the app.
It's a app.
And we, we talked for a few weeks
- A few a month.
- A month.
(Laughter)
We talked for a month.
- I love your relationship already.
- I'm like, after 3 hours
Don't you wanna know if you wanna
talk to me on the phone?
Come on.
- [ Kelly ] Wait, what happened when
you finally met in person?
- Okay, so well
- Date got rained out socially
distanced out outdoor park.
- Oh no
- We're gonna have a
little picnic and it rains.
And I thought, oh my gosh, is this a sign?
And I was like, no, no, no
it's fine cuz it's good
luck and it's fine.
It's also a first date
- I love rain.
- Yeah, right.
It's romantic.
It can be.
- Yeah [ Kelly ]
- Anyhow, we didn't go to the park.
- Oh, let's escape inside and make out.
- Yeah.
I was like, oh well what
about going to your house?
And he's like, I don't know.
Like, I haven't met you yet.
Like I, I don't, yeah,
he's such a gentleman.
- [ Kelly ] I love that.
- I know obviously he waited
for a month to ask me for my phone number.
- So
- She's still bringing it up.
I like it.
- I know it's been three years almost.
I can't get over anything.
- I love it.
- But, I, I was like
well we can like social
distance in your house.
And he is like, okay.
So I literally like, I
was like, unlock the door
I'll come in and you just go to the couch.
Cause this is before you could test,
like there were no tests available.
- [ Kelly] Oh.
- So you couldn't even find
out if you were potentially sick or not.
Like, you know.
- [ Kelly] Yeah.
So I was like, we'll just
shout across the living room.
It's so romantic.
But that was our first date.
- Oh my gosh.
That's so funny.
So wait, so now you've
written a children's book.
So what, what made y'all wanna do this?
What made you wanna do this together?
- There's several different
reasons, but I think that
while we were getting to know each other
And that's what you did
in the pandemic, because
- [ Kelly] Yeah.
- You had to really talk to
really get to know people other
- Well most people broke
up in the pandemic,
- right?
- Yeah. It happened to the best of us.
Um but, but, but
- Its all for the better
- It's rare that
It it's rare though
when people got together
with someone in the pandemic.
- Agreed.
- So did y'all just vibe right
off the bat and you both love
- Yeah
- Yeah, we did
- [ Kelly] love writing.
- We have all the same
friends in Nashville.
Bradley's been, you know,
in music publishing.
He was, now he's a songwriter
and so it's all like the
same world, you know?
- [ Kelly] Yeah.
- And we have, you know
very like-minded attitude about things.
And so we just got to talking
and I was like, you know
what are things that are
really important to you?
And of course we talked
about inner child stuff and
- [ Kelly] Yeah.
- Things that we wanted to hear, like
from our parents or mentors or
teachers when we were young.
And so this is really sort
of what inspired the book.
- Yeah. Yeah.
What, what made you wanna do it Bradley?
- Well, I had a grandfather
that was very sick
when I was young.
And I, I remember thinking,
you know, my mom's stressed
my dad, my whole family is
stressed out about this.
And it's for the age of this book
and it's a introduction
to prayer for children.
- Yeah.
- Because I was thinking,
I don't know how I can
can I talk to this higher power?
Can I talk to God?
Can I ask him for help?
And this book
the general introduction is
all done through animals.
- Yes. So I love it.
It's beautiful.
- Well, thank you.
- I literally, I was like
crying looking at the,
first of all the
illustrations are beautiful
- Lisa Fields.
She's incredible.
- Yeah. And it's just special.
And I like how you did
take different animals
like throughout the, which is funny
we have animals here today with love.
Yeah,
- baby.
- Oh my God.
So cute.
- I know.
- So cute.
Let's take another short break.
Chrissy and Bradley's book
is called, when I Talk to God
I talk about You Beautiful title.
And it's available now.
Everybody go get it.